hello and welcome everyone to today's
brilliant minds bold questions virtual
talk our series spotlights high impact
research from across the academy from
computer science population and public
health to economics and today molecular
microbiology if you are not familiar
with us cfar is a global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing science and humanity
my name is rachel parker i am senior
director of research at cfar and it is
my distinct pleasure to introduce you to
our two speakers for today's talk on how
do we get to net zero
first we have curtis berlingett who is
professor of chemistry and chemical
biological engineering at the university
of british columbia
curtis leads an interdisciplinary team
seeking ways to discover and scale
disruptive
clean energy materials his academic
group advances fundamental science and a
range of clean energy applications
including co2 utilization and advanced
nuclear fusion
also joining us is yogesh surendranath
or yogi who is an associate professor of
chemistry at the massachusetts institute
of technology
research in yogi's group aims to use
renewable electricity to rearrange
chemical bonds by controlling inter
facial reactivity at the molecular level
the chemistry of these interfaces is at
the heart of nearly all contemporary
challenges in renewable energy storage
and utilization in a wide variety of
technologies
addressing this challenge is essential
for enabling a low carbon energy future
today's session will last approximately
30 minutes
i will start the session with a question
before inviting our speakers to
interview one another for about 20 to 25
minutes and after this i'll open the
floor back up to questions from
participants online
if you as an online audience member have
a question you can use the q a function
to submit it we ask that you not use the
chat function to submit questions
lastly this session is being recorded
and will be available on the cfar
website next week
welcome curtis and yogi
so to get us started we know that co2
and other heat trapping gases are the
main drivers of global warming
to avoid the worst consequences of
global warming we will need to reach net
zero in our carbon footprint in less
than 30 years obviously this is no
simple task
what is missing from the current
research agenda that can aim to address
the carbon threat
thanks rachel and good morning good
afternoon everyone
um so so uh yogi so so chemists
worldwide
are
working to design catalysts that will
speed up critical chemical reactions
needed to convert renewable resources
such as biomass into fuels and chemicals
so yogi what is a catalyst and what does
it do
thanks curtis so um catalysis and
catalysis science is really at the heart
of many of the challenges we face in
decarbonizing the global energy system
and what what a catalyst really is a
material a molecule it can be many
things but its function is what's
critical it serves the role of neither
being produced nor consumed in the
overly
the overarching chemical reaction
but it serves a function of essentially
chaperoning the reactants towards
products across a low energy
high efficiency pathway
and in doing so it allows us to carry
out chemical reactions much faster than
without a catalyst and in the cases of
energy driven processes with much lower
energy input than we would need if we
didn't have a catalyst or if we didn't
have the most optimal catalyst the other
thing a catalyst really does it's
equally important is it defines
what the products are it it sets whether
you turn a reactant into one product or
50 000 products
and and how you choose which product you
get is critical to how much energy you
put in the process how useful and
valuable that product is um and indeed
if you think about the conversion of co2
into fuels or chemicals you'd want um uh
the optimal distribution of those fuel
molecules or chemical molecules for a
given application whether it be in the
aviation sector or in other areas of our
economy but you don't want molecules
that would be deleterious to their end
point use
and so catalysis plays this essential
role in guiding reactions towards one
desired product over another
thereby minimizing the costs that would
otherwise accrue from needing to do
energy intensive separations of the
products afterwards
and in allowing us to access the
materials that we would like with the
least amount of energy input
so let me turn the floor back over to
curtis actually so
you know i'm a catalyst science person
but one thing that we've actually
learned over the years is that the the
discovery of new materials new catalysts
new technologies
for a lot of these grand decarbonization
challenges can take quite a long time
and many times we don't even know the
principles or we don't know the unknown
unknowns on that journey towards new
technologies um curtis i would like to
turn the floor over to you and ask what
is your research
group doing really to shorten that
development time scale
yeah
and shortening that development time
scale is critical for us in terms of
solving the co2 problem because we don't
have a lot of time available to come up
with with big solutions
and and so one of the things our group
is very motivated by are
recent advances in robotics and
automation
um big data
and machine learning
and what we're doing is we're we're
taking all three of these aspects and
we're bringing them into the research
laboratory so that way we can actually
make smart robots to make self-driving
robots that actually will help us
make decisions on the experiments that
we're making in the lab
and and our mission here is to be able
to
accelerate the
the time it takes to take a new
discovery in the in the laboratory out
in the marketplace by at least ten fold
um and one of the challenges that we
have with hard tech commercializing hard
tech and taking things out of the
laboratory and into the marketplace is
that it tends to take over a decade
often a couple of decades or more
and when we look into the future we we
want to have some co2 technologies that
are out in the market um within the next
decade not not two decades from now and
and so uh
um what we're trying to do is is be able
to leverage all of these recent advances
in automation to be able to help us do
that to help the researchers in the lab
collect more data to collect higher
fidelity data and to also to be able to
use algorithms to help process the data
that's actually being being created and
assimilate that information into
discovering new materials making new
devices and advancing those devices
and then putting them into practice
um you know we just when we look back
over the course of history if we look at
fuel cells for example it's it's taken
three plus decades for fuel cells to
start hitting the market which they're
they're really just doing over the last
few years and we we really think that we
can learn
from information from that particular
sector and and help us accelerate the
development of these different
technologies so this is something that
that very much motivates us
curtis if i could if i can follow up on
that actually in in in the domain of of
using automation uh some of the
challenges in deploying green
technologies is the challenges the
unforeseen challenges that occur when
they get scaled up
um
talk to me about how automation if you
feel it can can can even accelerate and
perhaps foreshadow those challenges that
may occur upon the long long term
deployment or the scale up of certain
technologies
yeah um
so i i think
automation can help at
various stages in the in the development
process
in the lab it can help us find new
materials
we can then potentially use robotics to
take those new materials and to
implement them into devices
and that process that step of actually
taking a brand new material and putting
it into a vice that that is a slow step
in the lab today testing those materials
in that device is a slow step for today
um and so being able to bring in
automation and particularly new
algorithms that are coming online to
help us process data that are coming out
of that we we're we're really confident
that we can shorten the the timelines
from from getting from the lab again to
to a commercial product
one of the challenges that that we have
um as researchers though is that it's
it's really difficult to put automation
into action
um typically what happens is you
you you have to buy a robot from a
vendor but
most of these robots that are
commercially available can only do one
specific task and most of the research
that takes place in the university
environment requires a number of
different tasks okay so humans have the
uh incredible dexterity and this ability
to pivot on the fly to do different
experiments to get creative and shipped
and so one of the
the core features of our program is
we're actually um really trying to to
promote this concept of flexible
automation making robots that can change
on the fly with you change with the
experiment and evolve with the
experiments as you're understanding the
experiments um start to change and that
way you're not having to build a brand
new robot for every single step because
if you have to build a brand new robot
for every single step that's going to be
slower than the current process today so
it's definitely not a solid problem and
there's uh several of us around the
world right now that are really trying
to more rapidly um bring robotics into
the laboratory so that way we can use
automation and machine learning to its
its fullest extent so yogi i know uh you
know you work on something that that i'm
super interested in and that that's
really the chemistry at the interface
right that's that's really where all the
action happens and so can you explain to
everyone here how
something so seemingly small in scale
really just those those atoms that exist
right at the interface has such a huge
impact on the properties of the devices
that we're making for
really making renewable capturing
renewable energy and converting that
renewable energy into into useful forms
of energy
yeah yeah thanks chris the the you know
um we i've been captivated in that
problem of interfaces and interfacial
reactivity for for a long time really
the entirety of my independent career
and and i i got drawn to that by sort of
a kind of a key point really is that
that um one way i like to think about it
is that a lot of the processes we want
to drive involve moving things against
thermodynamic gradients moving
essentially rolling balls uphill we want
to take energy poor molecules turn them
into energy rich molecules and and
electricity is a powerful force for
actually driving those reactions uphill
and you can ask so where does
electricity
carried in sort of macroscopic wires
meet
molecules and their inner conversion
reactions it turns out where that occurs
is at interfaces it occurs in the
interfaces of our our cell phone
batteries it occurs um in the interfaces
of a fuel cell an electrolyzer that's
making renewable hydrogen or converting
co2 to a fuel
and and and the interesting thing that's
so fascinating actually is that despite
the critical role that these interfa and
the reason that's so critical is because
that's where the electrons that come in
by a charge separation in a circuit meet
the molecules that they're going to do
reactions on
and so the the properties of that
interface are so critical to defining
how catalytic transformations occur and
particularly energy relevant
transformations occur
what has gratified us and really been
interested to think about and this is
why i think you know cfarz and their
support has been been central to this
really is is
that that the problems around how we
think about interfaces despite how
important they are
the basic understanding of how they
function how they rearrange how they
degrade how they operate under realistic
conditions is still very much in its
infancy we're trying to drive a ferrari
without knowing how the parts are put
together in a sense in most of the
devices that we make um and so you can
imagine that when your cell phone
battery dies that becomes a
a more of a phenomenology than something
that we can look up in a textbook and be
like ah that's the reason that the cell
phone battery degraded after this amount
of cycle number right um we're still at
a place where we we get those pieces of
information from the laboratory and
we're sort of left scratching our heads
wondering why that is and that's because
at an atomistic level we don't have a
robust understanding of how interfaces
work
they provide these exotic environments
one thing that makes me so so amazed is
you know that the interfaces they
generate separations of charge that
generate some of the largest known
electric fields in chemistry um you get
enormous electric fields on the order of
tens of megavolts per centimeter over
the length scale of just a few atoms and
this allows you to literally rip bonds
apart and and we've been doing this in
electron we've been ripping some of the
strongest bonds apart the bonds between
aluminum and oxygen apart to make the
aluminum that we put in all of our
planes um and and and we still don't
even for that process know how that
works uh and and so a lot of what my
group really studies is how does at an
atomistic level how can you use these
enormous electric fields that happen at
an interface
to drive reactions um against their
their native um propensity to go
downhill along a free energy gradient so
so we want to take take energy poor
molecules turn them in energy-rich
molecules the way we use it the way we
do that is by taking interfacial fields
to literally rearrange those bonds uh
and and we try to unpack those
mechanisms and then use that to then
design new materials in a systematic way
this is the is the challenge you're
faced with today is that we just don't
have the tools available to really dial
into that particular region of study
yeah so the issue with interfaces is
it's a needle in the haystack problem
right because you have the bulk of your
electrode or your material and you have
the bulk of your solution or your
electrolyte
and even though those are 99.9
of the system it's that 0.01 right at
the interface that defines whether the
whole thing works or not uh and and so
so we really have a paucity of tools if
you we don't have the microscopes to
hone in on what's happening in the
interface without the the sort of
clutter and background and fog of all
the stuff that's happening in solution
or in the solid
and that's really a core of the
challenge and one of the ways we've
really addressed that challenge is not
necessarily by making a better
microscope but by making better ways to
implant something very precisely at the
interface and asking from that how does
that lead to specific effects so in a
way we don't try to measure the needle
in the haystack we try to implant a very
shiny needle in the haystack that can
serve as a beacon for us to understand
that outside of all of the fog
very cool
so so speaking of an interfacial problem
you know
one of the interfacial problems that
that
both of us have a lot of interest in is
is converting co2 into valuable
chemicals and fuels uh so talk to me
about that curtis what can we convert
co2 into um what are the useful things
that we can make it into and how would
we go about doing that
right
yeah um just to calibrate everybody so
uh
yogi and i are very much interested in
finding ways that we can use clean
renewable electricity to drive these
transformations of co2 into something
useful
and
ultimately what the commercial device
will look like
is is like a water electrolyzer um so a
co2 electrolyzer think of it just as a
as a big box where you've got co2 going
in one side with water and electricity
and then on the other side you're going
to you're going to have a liquid
byproduct and you're going to you're
going to have some chemical byproduct
containing that upgraded carbon so that
co2 has been upgraded to some carbon
species
and and the beautiful thing about
co2 electrochemistry
is that there are a wide range of
products that you can make within that
electrolyzer by applying really the same
amount of electrical energy the choice
of a product that comes out on the other
end all comes back to the identity of
that catalyst that you put into the
electrolyzer and this is gets back to
the
first point that yogi was making earlier
today the
the catalyst play such a critical role
in dictating
how that co2 gets converted into
something useful so what are some of the
the products that could potentially be
coming out on the other end
um one of the products that we like to
make is carbon monoxide okay so no one
wants to go to the store to buy carbon
monoxide to get it but you can take that
carbon monoxide in a chemical plant and
it ends up being a very useful building
block it's a very reactive species and
you can convert you can polymerize that
carbon monoxide into useful plastics or
other carbon containing materials
you can actually mix it with hydrogen
which is actually a byproduct that comes
out of the electrolyzer so you're
effectively making syngas and so there's
an opportunity there to actually just
use
that product that's coming out of the
other end and actually do further
processing to convert it into fuels that
can then be used
um there's a range of other products
that you make you know acetic acid
formic acid ethylene and they're there
are now thousands of researchers around
the world that are uh all trying to
um really manipulate the catalyst and
the engineering of the electrolyzer to
be able to make these these different
products
um but one of the things that we've been
really thinking a lot about in our group
is just like if you could actually make
all of those carbon products that like
all the plastics in the world um
everything outside of liquid fuels what
what you know what how much co2 are you
actually going to be fixing
and um and so this has actually forced
us down this path of really thinking
through
what type of product should we be
converting co2 into
and and this exercise has actually
helped us converge on really focusing on
building materials um
we really are incented to try to figure
out how can we
take co2 from the atmosphere and convert
it into cement for example and why we
like cement is that if you're going to
take that co2 convert it into cement
that cement is going to be fixed in
place for several decades
and that's one of the other things that
we have to take into consideration the
choice of the co2 products that we're
making because if we're just going to
utilize that that that carbon based
product and combust it and return that
co2 back to the atmosphere in a very
short time frame we're not necessarily
solving the problem and so this is just
another challenge that we have in the
co2 sciences is figuring out what
product are we going to make in which
we're fixing that carbon for a really
long time period and so building
materials seems like one of those
candidate materials that not a lot of
people are looking at right now
people are starting to look at that and
but we see that as a huge opportunity
for our field moving forward
curtis a corollary to that is um co2 is
only at about 400 ppm in the atmosphere
though rising fast fast um um but but
that doesn't seem very concentrated how
do we get the co2
that we would use to convert into all of
these valuable products
right um so we're we're really relying
on different technologies to to capture
that co2 either from from air
um or from from uh
from the flu stack of different plants
but ultimately uh we need to solve this
problem but really probably by by taking
that co2 from the atmosphere in some way
and there are quite a different
quite a few different ways of doing that
today and
lots of different technologies that are
out there and
i i really think that what's important
for our community is to make sure that
our co2 utilization community is really
thinking about how that co2 is captured
so the the challenge that the co2
capture folks have is that if they have
a technology that captures co2 readily
that same material that captured the co2
is not likely going to want to give up
that co2 very easily and so as a result
there's an energy penalty associated
with releasing that co2 so then you can
either store it or feed it into your co2
electrolyzer down the road and so
finding something that captures that co2
very quickly and at scale
and then is willing to release that co2
with as little energy as possible is
really the grand challenge for us in the
co2 sciences
and something that our cfar program is
is very motivated to do
is actually look at coupling these two
communities of co2 capture and co2
utilization and bring our different
communities our different technologies
together to see if we can do everything
in one single unit
instead of operating as silos which
really is how we've the two communities
have been operating over the last few
years
so yogi i mentioned catalyst
can you mention a little bit more about
what the specific properties of catalyst
that you're looking at and how
specifically you can tune the
performance
yeah sure so so catalyst design is a
kind of a grand challenge that as i
think curtis and i both talked about
pervades a lot of these challenges in
green technologies and co2
utilization
what we really look for in catalysis is
something that really will accelerate
the reaction as much as possible that's
sort of the
the rate at which the catalyst turns
over the reactant in the product another
feature we really look for in a catalyst
is something that will form a single
product over many products that's the
question of selectivity
the first one is a question of
efficiency or or sort of performance of
the catalyst second one is related to
the selectivity of the catalyst and then
there's a very key and often overlooked
parameter that's equally important in
catalyst science
which is the durability of your catalyst
whether its ability to catalyze that
reaction and its ability to do it
selectively to a single value-added
product does that remain the same over
time or after running it a hundred or a
thousand hours does it then degrade and
is no longer useful of course you can
imagine that a catalyst needs to have a
durability on the order
of the lifetime of the types of devices
we anticipate deploying for co2
utilization which we we would be we
would imagine are on the order of many
decades right so so in the in the same
way that the curtis and i have a shared
interest in in looking at catalysts for
co2 conversion while the community has
made i would say really amazing progress
over the last decade or so in developing
new catalysts new understanding of their
mechanisms of action and new ways of
controlling their selectivity and
efficiency
we still haven't yet gotten a good sense
for whether those catalysts will have
the requisite durability to be able to
make it in a device for two decades or
three decades right um and and in many
cases it's not easy to test that in the
laboratory um and oftentimes it's not
easy because in a real operating system
your catalyst may be exposed to tiny
amounts of foreign materials or poisons
or other species that you don't often
simulate for in the laboratory um and
and so so that that remains just a very
much an open challenge for catalysis
science but critical to the to the you
to the deployment of these technologies
so a follow-up question on on that if i
could just interject here as well um i'm
curious what the biggest barriers are
for the adoption of green technology
from a commercialization standpoint
you know yogi just touched on the on the
big one and that is proving out uh
technology can survive in the real world
for several years if not a decade or
more
and
we simply don't have a lot of tools
available to us that allow us to do the
accelerated testing that is reliable
enough that gives the people that are
going to go out and commercialize these
technologies the comfort to both invest
in it and to be able to introduce those
those products into their plan
so durability i would say is probably
the the
it is the one step that takes the
longest to prove out because ultimately
you have to run the experiment before a
lot of people will invest and use it and
so coming up with new ways to
to really try to understand how we can
get information on how a system will
behave years into the future is it needs
to become a more important
area of science and engineering for the
community
i would say that the other limitation
until the last couple of years of course
is is really the capital available to be
able to go out and pursue many of these
technologies
there was a lot of money that
got injected into cleantech in the early
part of the century
and after 2008
a lot of that capital disappeared and
clean tech became a very bad word in the
investment world
um what's happening today is now people
are a lot more sensitive to global
warming they're they're impacted
directly by global warming and now
everybody's realizing that we really do
need to invest in this and so i'm i'm
actually really excited to see how much
capital is coming back into looking at
clean energy technologies
and carbon capture carbon utilization
these are some some very hot areas for
investment right now and this is really
how you drive change so i'm really
excited to to see the the interest that
and support that we're getting from
beyond the science community that we
actually weren't getting even a couple
of years ago
that seems to me like a perfect ending
point uh for today let's end on a note
of optimism for the future um and and
hope that uh we've captured people's um
uh imagination and interest in in the
subject and uh we wish you all the all
the best and uh thank you so much yogi
and curtis for taking your time to talk
with us today
we look forward to watching your program
in future and thanks everybody for
watching it from home
thank you thank you thank you to c5
[Music]
you